Trascrizione: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Ariana Bleau Lugo
Buongiorno a tutti.
Io lavoro in un paese
che non è né molto famoso
né molto conosciuto
che si chiama Timor Est.
È un paese a metà strada
tra l'Australia e l'Indonesia
che ha avuto per 25 anni
una lunghissima guerra civile
con l'Indonesia
che ha lasciato il paese
praticamente distrutto.
Essendo uno dei paesi
più poveri dell'Asia
ci sono chiaramente tantissimi problemi
di natura economica e sociale
che vanno ancora risolti.
Io sono arrivato a Timor Est
come tutte le persone
che fanno un po' il mio lavoro
un po' per caso un po' per scelta,
ma sempre seguendo il filo logico
di un pensiero, una considerazione
che mi ha sempre accompagnato,
sia nella mia vita da studente
sia in quella professionale.
E la curiosità è questa:
noi sicuramente viviamo in un mondo
che ha un livello di sviluppo
tecnologico avanzatissimo.
Abbiamo raggiunto la luna
50 anni fa;
riusciamo a fare
delle operazioni chirurgiche
che sono sicuramente complessisime;
abbiamo un sistema di comunicazione
che è globale.
Per esempio, io sono in video skype,
con la mia bimba che ha 6 anni,
da Timor Est,
con i nonni qui a Trento ogni domenica.
Una cosa che sicuramente
fa molto felice i nonni,
ma che 10 anni fa,
era considerata fantascienza.
Ecco, io mi sono sempre domandato:
ma con tutta questa tecnologia
a disposizione dell'umanità,
perché un miliardo di persone
soffre ancora la sete,
non ha a disposizione acqua potabile?
Non è forse più facile mettere
acquedotti e rubinetti in Africa,
piuttosto che mandare
una sonda spaziale su Marte?
Quest'oggi vorrei parlare con voi
di uno dei grandi problemi
che tutt'oggi affligge l'umanità
e che è il problema
della mortalità infantile.
Ogni anno, nel mondo,
4 milioni di bambini muoiono
per cause che sarebbero
facilmente prevenibili
prima di raggiungere
i 28 giorni di età, un mese di età.
4 milioni sono veramente tanti:
circa 11.000 ogni giorno.
Vorrei far vedere questa diapositiva
che rappresenta il problema
in maniera un po' più precisa.
Sono tutti i dati dell'OMS
basati sulla ricerca dell'ente del 2005.
Come possiamo vedere
da quella curva che scende,
la mortalità nei bambini
al di sotto dei 5 anni
è decresciuta in maniera davvero
rilevante negli ultimi cinquant'anni.
Questo grazie
a campagne di vaccinazione,
grazie al controllo della diarrea,
grazie a una maggior igiene,
grazie allo sviluppo economico
delle società.
Invece, se guardiamo quelle barrette
verticali sul fondo del grafico,
rappresentano la mortalità infantile,
la parte gialla rappresenta
la mortalità infantile precoce,
cioè quella nei primi 7 giorni di vita
che sono i più pericolosi
e i più delicati per un neonato.
Ecco possiamo vedere
che la mortalità nei neonati
e soprattutto la mortalità nei neonati
nella prima settimana di vita
è rimasta praticamente la stessa,
negli ultimi 50 anni,
nonostante tutto lo sviluppo tecnologico
che abbiamo avuto
nel settore della medicina.
Se vogliamo raggiungere
gli obiettivi del millennio nel 2015,
se vogliamo veramente ridurre
in maniera ulteriore
la mortalità nei bambini,
dobbiamo concentrarci
in quel periodo della vita
che è più pericoloso.
Dobbiamo partire
dai primissimi istanti di vita.
Ma perché continuano a morire
i neonati nei Paesi in via di sviluppo?
Bè, sicuramente ci sono tantissimi
motivi per cui questo succede.
Motivi di ordine culturale,
antropologico, economico.
Si potrebbero scrivere
10 saggi sul problema.
Io oggi vorrei sottolineare con voi
uno di questi problemi
che però è importantissimo.
Questa foto è stata scattata
nel centro del Vietnam
circa 5 anni fa.
Ma potrebbe essere stata scattata
una settimana fa in Africa,
oppure un mese fa nel Centro America.
Secondo l'OMS,
l'Organizzazione Mondiale della Sanità,
il 90% dei macchinari medici
donati o acquistati dai
Paesi in via di sviluppo
smette di funzionare
entro un anno dal loro acquisto.
Questo succede chiaramente
per vari motivi,
ma uno dei motivi principali è perché
nei Paesi in via di sviluppo
non esiste un ecosistema di supporto
che permette a questi macchinari
di funzionare in maniera adeguata.
Quindi se i macchinari si rompono
non esistono in loco i pezzi ricambio.
Se anche pezzi ricambio ci fossero,
non esistono
degli ingegneri biomedici adeguati
che possono cambiare i pezzi
e rimettere le machine in funzione.
Gli ospedali nei Paesi in via di sviluppo
sono diversissimi
da quelli nei Paesi occidentali.
Sono disorganizzati, c'è molta polvere,
alle volte ci sono pure degli insetti
e quindi macchinari molto costosi,
ma anche molto delicati,
si rovinano subito nel contesto
dei Paesi in via di sviluppo.
Quindi ci troviamo con questa situazione:
i macchinari in un cortile
a prendere polvere
e 100 metri più in là,
i neonati che muoiono
nell'ala pediatrica dell'ospedale.
Quindi che cosa fare di fronte
a un problema di queste dimensioni?
Circa 10 anni fa, in Vietnam,
io stavo lavorando
per la cooperazione trentina
con due organizzazioni
molto piccole ma molto dinamiche
appunto del Trentino:
il "Gruppo trentino di volontariato"
e gli "Amici della neonatologia trentina."
Tra i vari progetti di cui mi occupavo,
stavo lavorando con l'ospedale locale
del villaggio dove vivevo,
una cittadina a metà strada
tra noi e la Cina.
L'ospedale in questione
aveva un numero di parti
che era davvero rilevante:
circa 15.000 nati ogni anno.
Per fare un confronto, in Trentino,
in un anno nascono circa 5.000 neonati.
Quindi questo ospedale aveva, da solo,
tutti i neonati del Trentino per 3 volte.
Il 30% dei neonati ricoverati
nella pediatria di questo ospedale
moriva entro una settimana di vita.
Non ce la faceva proprio.
Oppure quei pochi che avevano
qualche speranza di cavarsela
venivano mandati ad Hanoi
su una motoretta oppure su un carretto,
insomma con mezzi di fortuna:
non era ancora il tempo delle ambulanze.
Arrivavano chiaramente ad Hanoi
in condizioni critiche
e la maggior parte, comunque, moriva.
Ecco, nella ricerca di una soluzione
a questo problema,
ho incontrato un ingegnere americano
che erano moltissimi anni
che lavorava in questo settore in Vietnam.
Cercava in tutti i modi di riparare
le macchine mediche,
di creare un database
di quale macchina esistessero
e di quali pezzi ricambio
fossero necessari e disponibili.
Dopo un po' si era arreso all'evidenza
che era impossibile creare
un sistema artificiale
che facesse funzionare
questi macchinari medici
nell'ambiente del Vietnam in quel caso.
E così gli era venuta l'idea
di realizzare in loco,
con materiali e con ingegneri locali
tutte quelle tecnologie mediche
necessarie alla sopravvivenza dei neonati.
A me chiaramente l'idea
fin dall'inizio mi ha affascinato
e quindi abbiamo deciso di lavorare
insieme su questo progetto.
La prima cosa che ci siamo domandati
è perché muoiono esattamente
i neonati ricoverati nell'area neonatale.
Quello che abbiamo scoperto
è che la maggior parte dei neonati
nasceva prematuro
e quindi moriva per una problematica
che è molto comune
alla maggior parte nati prematuri
che sono le insufficienze respiratorie.
I bambini di 25 o 30 settimane
di età gestazionale
non hanno ancora i polmoni
che sono maturati
e quindi non riescono a dare
abbastanza ossigeno al corpo
e muoiono dopo vari giorni di lavoro
per cercare di avere
abbastanza ossigeno nei tessuti.
Quindi con questo ingegnere americano
avevamo deciso di provare a costruire
qualcosa che fosse adatto
ai Paesi in via di sviluppo
e quindi abbiamo creato una macchina
fatta in loco,
fatta da ingegneri vietnamiti
e che potesse essere adatta
ai Paesi in via di sviluppo.
Quindi la macchina non è costruita
secondo il principio di come
l'ospedale dovrebbe essere
o come l'ospedale
ci piacerebbe che fosse.
È costruita secondo il modo
in cui l'ospedale, purtroppo, è.
E quindi ecco che, per esempio,
visto che elettricità è assolutamente
instabile nei Paesi in via di sviluppo,
la macchina ha uno stabilizzatore interno
che stabilizza l'elettricità
e la protegge.
Visto che i dottori non sono molto
esperti nella terapia respiratoria,
la macchina è semplicissima:
ha solamente tre funzioni
e 5 bottoni:
non uno di più, per poter esser usata
in tutti i contesti possibili.
La macchina è completamente sigillata:
non c'è nessun buco oppure
porta USB che permetta alla polvere
o all'umidità di entrare
e di distruggerla.
Ma, soprattutto,
tutti i circuiti della macchina
sono completamente lavabili.
Possono essere lavati,
asciugati, sterilizzati
e poi riutilizzati
per il prossimo paziente
in modo che la possano usare
per anni e anni
dopo che sia stata donata.
Siamo riusciti a fare una macchina
che funziona praticamente in ogni ambiente
ed è in grado di salvare la vita
a quei neonati
che altrimenti sarebbero morti
di stress respiratorio.
All'inizio abbiamo chiaramente
fatto un progetto pilota
in un ospedale specifico del Vietnam
e c'era bisogno di un sostegno, un aiuto,
per realizzare
tutta la parte di clinica medica,
tutti i protocolli d'uso,
quando utilizzarla, quando smetterla,
quali bambini scegliere.
E questo è stato realizzato tutto
da medici volontari trentini
del Santa Chiara di Trento
oppure della Rete ospedaliera trentina
in un progetto di sviluppo
finanziato dalla Provincia di Trento.
Il progetto ha avuto un successo
davvero strepitoso:
un'ampia riduzione
della mortalità infantile
nella prima settimana di vita,
una riduzione dei trasferimenti ad Hanoi,
una riduzione della metà
del tempo di trattamento dei neonati.
E quindi ci siamo incoraggiati
da questi risultati
e abbiamo fatto il prossimo ospedale,
poi quello dopo e poi quello dopo
fino a che la fondazione Midwest,
che è una fondazione in California,
una delle più grandi agenzie di sviluppo
presente nel Sud Est Asiatico,
ha notato le potenzialità
di questo modello
e ha deciso di creare un programma
che si chiama "Breath of life",
soffio di vita, che intende sostenere
questo modello di sviluppo per tutti
gli ospedali del sud est asiatico
e adesso anche dell'Africa.
Io non ho molto tempo a disposizione,
quindi vorrei riassumere
una storia di 10 anni:
abbiamo già distribuito quasi
1.000 macchinari in 300 ospedali
del Sud Est Asiatico e dell'Africa
e anche del Sud Asia come l'India.
Pensate che ci sono 50 mila
neonati ogni anno
che sono, al giorno d'oggi,
in trattamento con le tecnologie
donate e procurate
dal nostro programma.
Ecco, in conclusione, io vorrei tornare
a quello che dicevamo all'inizio.
Alla domanda che mi facevo sia all'inizio
dei miei studi e del mio lavoro.
Come è possibile che con tutta questa
tecnologia a disposizione nel mondo,
un miliardo di persone
soffre ancora la sete?
Devo essere sincero:
non ne ho la più pallida idea.
lo so, però, che con un design
che sia innovativo,
con un design che guardi
ai bisogni concreti e reali
di chi utilizza le tecnologie
e non di chi le produce,
e con una logica
che non guardi al profitto,
ma che guardi ai risultati
che si ottengono nella pratica medica,
come in altri campi dell'attività umana,
è possibile raggiungere
un modello di sviluppo tecnologico
che sia appropriato, prima di tutto,
ma poi che sia anche efficace
per i risultati che ottiene,
e che sia, soprattutto,
sostenibile nel tempo.
E questo è il programma Breath of life.
Grazie a tutti per l'attenzione.